hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation titled development
of an affordable covid19 vaccine based
on a new castle disease virus platform
this webinar is part of the 2021
microbiology virtual week and i am susie
valdez of labyrinths and i will be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots so let's get
started before we begin i want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you'd
like during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
and if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation simply click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right hand corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits
i now present today's speaker dr adolfo
garcia sastre professor of the
department of microbiology and medicine
at tisch cancer center icon school of
medicine at mount sinai for a complete
biography of our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen dr garcia sastre welcome you may
now begin your presentation sir
hi hello good morning or good afternoon
depending on where you are
um
i'm gonna be today
showing you some of the signs that let's
let us to
explore
the possibility of using
a platform vaccine platform based on a
viral vector newcastle disease virus
as a commit 19 vaccine and
why now
do we still need to have more vaccines
that's something that that will cover
and the potential advantages that this
vaccine platinum platform may have over
the already existing
vaccines that are in use and that
actually are performing
uh quite well
and and these studies have been mainly
the collaboration between three labs is
my lab
uh with the lab of peter palacio and the
lap of floyd cramer we are all
at the aiken school of medicine at mount
sinai application to the department of
microbiology
and we are also quite
helpful for the contribution of
different funding agencies including
nih and as well as some philanthropy uh
from the bill a melinda begins
foundation or for some other foundations
like the jpv foundation and the opp
foundation
all right
so
first um
what i'm saying now is some of the
strategies that have been used and are
still some of them in development for
coving 19 vaccination
this includes the use of inactivated
viruses in fact there are
some vaccines that have been
manufactured in china
that have been used in different
countries that use an inactivated
sarskoff ii
in order to induce immunity against the
saskop2
and attenuated
vaccines meaning
you need to somehow
make mutations in the sask of two virus
that now the virus is unable to induce
disease but it is still able to be
monogenic
and there is no one that no no
attenuated vaccine in use right now some
of the difficulties with attenuated
vaccines is to achieve the right degree
of attenuations which make them safe
and perhaps this have uh making the
development of attenuated vaccines
a longer development but there are some
that are in the pipeline that may still
be used later on
and then there are vaccines that are not
based on on the virus itself either
inactivated or attenuated but they are
based on components of the virus
and all the vaccines that have been used
they are based on one of the component
of the virus which is the spike protein
the spike protein is the viral
glycoprotein that is the surface of the
virus that binds to the receptor and
antibodies against the spike protein
once they are induced by natural
infection or by vaccination with an
antigen that has the spike protein
will prevent
the infection by preventing binding of
the spike protein to its receptor in the
cell that is going to get infected
and that's the basis of the work of the
vaccines that are in use although
perhaps there is also some contribution
not only from antibodies but also from
cellular immunity but
we know that the vaccines that are in
use in these neutralizing antibodies
directed against the spike protein and
that these antibodies are able to
prevent binding of the spike protein to
the receptor
this has a good indication that the
levels of of antibodies that are induced
by vaccination by infection
correlate with the efficacy the highest
the levels of antibodies
the higher the efficacy for prevention
of infection with even with some of the
new variants
the vaccines that are based on
components of the virus on the spike
could be a protein subunit toxin that's
expressed in recombinant protein
these are this is for example the basis
for the novabax vaccine that has
conducted already some large scale
clinical trials but the spending of
submitting the results to the regulatory
agencies for potential use
approval use of the vaccine
and and then there are some obvious that
are based on viral vectors or in genetic
material of the virus the ones that are
have been successfully used in uh
as viral vector vaccines they are the
ones that use adenovirus vectors these
are
adenoviruses that instead of expressing
adenovirus proteins express the spike
protein of of cersei ii expression only
of the south uh cough ii spike protein
does not induce disease for that you
need valve replication uh but in use
antibodies against the spike and these
are for example the the vaccines of
johnson and johnson the single salt
vaccine that is used in this country in
the usa
or also the vaccine of astrazeneca that
is widely used in
many countries or the sputnik vaccine
which is the the
russian vaccine that is also used in
several countries
in terms of genetic vaccines the genetic
vaccines could be based on dna dna that
can cause the spike protein that has
been injected during vaccination and
this result in expression of rna in the
cells that this dna is taking up and the
rna gets converted into protein and if
the protein is the spike
then you get antibodies against the
spike or the rna vaccines that bypass
the use of dna by using directly
messenger rna that needs to be coded
with
with some
lipids in order to facilitate
the release of the rna in the cytoplasm
of the cell that is going to produce the
antigen which is where it needs to be
translated into into the spike viral
protein
in terms of the
um in addition to to these um
platforms
one need also to consider the
possibility of use of an adjuvant that's
important mainly for inactivated
vaccines and protein-supplemented
vaccines that require some help in order
to be more immunogenic the use of
nanoparticles is what is the case of the
rna vaccines that need to be
encapsulated into nanoparticles in order
to deliver well the rna inside the cell
where it's going to produce the protein
and in terms of the route of
administration of these vaccines all the
vaccines that have been approved are
intramuscular vaccines
there are some that are
that are in the pipeline that
are intranasal
this may have the giving advantage if
they work well
to induce very good local immunity in
the upper respiratory tract
which is where infection starts
the vaccines that are used right now
induce extremely good levels of
antibodies systemic antibodies
that circulate in blood this antibodies
reach very well the lung and the the the
and therefore in the lung will prevent
infection of the lung but these
antibodies that not reach so well the
upper respiratory tract and then
replication may be still possible in the
upper respiratory tract in vaccinated
people
this will not result in severe disease
for that device needs to go to the lung
inside but they will result in
asymptomatic infections of mild
infections that can lead to transmission
like what is happening for example in
many of the vaccine breakthroughs that
are happening
and that
in vaccinated individuals that's because
they
don't
these vaccines don't induce
verifications in new sound but not it's
a verification level of antibodies in
the upper respiratory tract
well with respect to
our contribution here in vaccines we
started first with the spike
and trying to understand
what form of the spike we need to use in
order to have good immunogenicity
and
thus we conducted some studies on that
some other vaccine platforms have
conducted similar studies but we started
by looking um to
any spike protein
that is identical in sequence to the
spike protein of the virus but then we
test it in as immunogens
some verses of the spikes that they
become stabilized
without changing their antigenic
properties this was achieved either by
eliminating the cleave site the cs or
clevis site of the spike protein
the spike protein needs to be clear in
order to be functional and this cleavage
makes the protein less stable so this is
good for the virus
but for an immunogen you prefer one
prefers to have a very stable immunogen
that does not fall apart
uh cleavage may allow this immunogen to
fall apart in some circumstances and
this will prevent induction with
antibodies so we eliminated the clivic
site in one version
in another version we introduced two
prolines in the carboxy terminal domain
of the spike protein that are known to
stabilize also the protein in the last
version we
include both modifications at the same
time modification of the clevis side
and
the two prolines that makes also the
entity more stable
we look them for expression so this is
using recombinant proteins they express
very well they express
in
in mammalian cells
and imbakulo insect cells also they
express nice levels of protein that can
be seen purified in a in a commercial
with high levels and
they look quite stable they don't have
any degradation products
and they also recognize very well with
antibodies like this particular antibody
that are known to neutralize the spikes
so that means that they are
conformationally correct
and they are and they are stable here in
with respect to precomponent protists
but we expect that the one that contains
the modification would be even more
stable when injected in the vaccines
the next experiment that we did is we
compare
these different versions in uh of
recombinant proteins in immunized mice
so we immunize mice intramuscularly with
these proteins we include an attribute
in order to be more immunogenic
immunogenic this other box which is an
achievement that is similar to mf59
which is an approved adjuvant for the
use in humans
we use a prima busta approach in the
mouth
and in order to be able to
not only
look for an induction of antibodies but
look for protection because the mice are
not susceptible to susceptible
infection we took this mice and then we
transduced them
we make them to express
the the receptor human ec2 in the lungs
through the use of a gene therapy vector
that has been internationally given to
the mice before challenge
now by this gene therapy vector the mice
will express now in the lungs the human
is two which is the receptor and the and
then they can be challenged and although
this is not a lethal challenge one can
look to a body weight drop four disease
as well as tires in the in the length of
these animals
so first we looked at the induction of
of antibodies by these different
vaccines
um which are here in the in the bottom
right of this of this slide
the green vaccine is the is the vaulted
protein induced antibodies after priming
but the one that contains the red one
the one that contains the cleave site
eliminated induce higher level of
antibodies
the one with only two prolines and the
the orange yellow one
induce a little bit less and the one
that has the two modifications induce
very good levels of antibodies also so
it looks like the climate site
elimination is contributed to high
induction of antibodies these are
antibodies that bind to the receptor
binding site of the protein measured in
the lysa assay and we look at both
boosts we have basically the same
results the ones that are giving higher
level of antibodies after boosting are
also the ones that have the clevis side
removed from the spike protein
so now um if we look now
not only to binding antibodies to the
spike um
here are binding antibodies in the
spikes in the in the left
uh which again are the ones that have
the clevis side removed the ones that
are a little higher
but we look to neutralize an activity of
these antibodies
now what we can see is that there is one
antigen that is much better in terms of
levels of neutralized antibodies and is
the one that contains the two
modifications
removal of the clevis site
and introduction of the two prolines
and if we now challenge these animals
with
sarskoff ii
then the animals that are not vaccinated
lose weight these are this is the black
line
with a peak at six days pause infection
and the ones that are vaccinated in
general they lose also some weight is
step with one exception
which is the one that has been
vaccinated
with the spike that contains the two
modifications both the cleaver side and
the two prolines that make it more
stable this in terms of disease body
weight loss
but if we look to viral titus
then what we see in viral titus is at
day two um
we have a reduction in biotitis in all
the animals that have been vaccinated
but we don't see in all the animals that
have been vaccinated with the spike that
contains the two modifications clevis
site and the two proles that stabilize
it
we don't see any virus at the two in the
lung and therefore they are all equal
identical but it looks
that from these studies
that the antigen contains the clevis
side remove of the spike and the two
problems that stabilize further the
spike is the antigen that induce better
protective immunity in mice
and this leads us now to our studies
with the newcastle disease viral vector
vector
so uh in this studies we have also been
using um
a stabilized spike protein to be
expressed not now as a recovering
protein like in the previous experiments
but now expressed by a viral vector in
this case a viral vector is newcastle
disease virus
so it's similar in terms of using a
viral vector to the adenovirus vaccines
but the virus vectors that's been used
is different adenoviruses say dna virus
newcastle disease various and rna virus
and it's a virus that it can infect
chicken avians indian species
especially chicken where it can induce a
very virulent disease which is called
newcastle disease
and because this was known for a while
that newcastle disease can infect
poultry and cause problems in poultry
there is a vaccine that has been
developed many years ago against
newcastle disease
in chicken
which is based in a new castle disease
virus strain that does not induce
disease in chicken but administration in
chicken will protect them from virulent
newcastle disease virus so the viral
vector that we are using for expressing
spike is based on these vaccines of
newcastle disease virus these vaccine
strains
that have been used for vaccination of
chicken against newcastle disease
therefore they are
safe for chicken
and
are known also to be safe for humans
which is also very important and most of
the studies that have been done with
this factor in our team has been done by
a very uh
talented person with nassan
that was the one that was
rescuing these viruses and using
viral vectors and using them for
vaccination in the different animal
models
now
why what
why would newcastle this is virus
what what what are the potential
advantages that this vaccine platform
may have
first there is no pre-existing immunity
in humans against these viral vectors
viral vectors may have a problem that if
there is an antibody in humans
people that have been vaccinated against
the viral vector that has been used then
the valve vector will not be able to
deliver
the genetic material is required for
expression of the spike
this could be a problem for example with
some of the adenovirus vaccines for
which the some people may have some
pre-existing immunity against the
adenovirus vector that is being used for
delivering the spike
newcastle disease
is a avian
mucosal disease virus and even pathogen
it does not infect in general humans so
we don't have pre-existing immunity
against the viral vector
the most important potential advantage
that this technology has
is that newcastle disease various
vaccines
the ones that are using chicken as well
as the ones that we have developed now
is present spiked protein they are
manufactured using the same technology
which is egg based as the influenza
various vaccines and this what it allows
is that any
production
of a facility for influenza virus
vaccines
could be used for producing a new castle
disease virus vaccine
and it grows very well in eggs it can be
grown in eggs and it can be used the egg
material be used for making the vaccine
seeds that are required for vaccination
similarly to what is done with influenza
various vaccines and there is many
countries even developing countries that
have
production facilities for influenza
vaccines
and they can use these facilities also
to now produce a new castle this is
virus-based vaccine
then it's important safety safety in
humans is important and clinical studies
in humans using newcastle this virus
especially that has been used for
potential treatment of tumors have
demonstrated a very good safety profile
so it seems it seems to be a safe
vaccine platform in humans
and
in addition we
have been using newcastle this virus
before as a vaccine vector
for chicken and in chicken we have a
very good
use of for example a dual vaccine
against newcastle and against influenza
avian influenza
by
a newcastle this is virus vaccine vector
that expressed not only newcastle these
virus proteins but also the hemoglobin
of influenza this surface glycoprotein
of influenza
in the past we have also generated
a newcastle disease virus vectors
expressing antigens from other different
infectious agents like for example
respiratory cereal virus
influenza virus that i mentioned um
already
ebola various
of one different stars or hiv antigens
and
they have been we have been tested in
uh preclinical animal models and they
seem to induce very good responses
against the the antigens that are being
expressed
and now um we have the newcastle this
virus pressing the spikes produce of
sarskoff ii and the clinical development
in several countries so we hope that uh
in the future in the near future
the clinical development will be
finished and this will be a new
vaccine that could be used
uh more easy to produce uh
more easy to administer also because
it's quite stable than any other
vaccines that are available right now
well so then how we do that newcastle
this virus has a genome that contains
all the viral proteins what we do is we
insert it into the genome of the virus a
new
transcriptional unit corresponded to the
sas coronavirus spike protein
and
we can do it uh
we we have this stabilizing mutations
that i mentioned before that we know
that will increase immunogenicity
removal of the clivicide
as well as
introduction of problems to stabilize it
but in addition we can also make one
more modification which will be the
carboxy terminal region of the protein
the one that anchors the protein into
the membrane
we have made a version in newcastle
disease virus that has
removal these transmembrane cytoplasmic
domain of the protein
and
substitution replacement with the
transmembrane plasmic domain of one of
the proteins of newcastle disease virus
and what we achieve with that
is we have incorporation of the spike
protein of saskof2
into the envelope of the newcastle
disease period so the viruses the
newcastle these virus vectors not only
express
a spike when infecting a new cell
but also they have the spike decorating
the the virus surface this is not the
case with the adenovectors that they
have
a viral surface for which they cannot uh
insert the spike antivirus vectors will
only express the spike in the in the
places that they they will infect in the
case of these vectors the newcastle this
virus vector
by doing this trick with the
transmembrane domain not only the virus
that the cells that are being infected
with the virus when the this vaccination
will express a spike
but also the spike is incorporated into
into the variance
the spike is expressed very well um the
stabilizer spikes as compared to the
non-stabilized spikes that they get
clear and they get expressed less
and then in terms of production they can
be put in in in x produced in x and this
results in generation of variants
containing the spike here in green
decorating the variance
and because of this modality that they
have this spike in the surface we can
test two modalities of vaccination
one is we can inactivate the viruses
and then we can inject it
intramuscularly
and that will be the similar to an
activated
valve vaccine or we can use it as a life
vaccine because this virus does not
induce this is in humans either
intramuscularly or intranetically which
may allow better protection of the upper
respiratory tract and in this case not
only the
it would induce an immune response
because of the antigen that is
decorating the virus
but also because the virus will be able
to get into some cells and express the
spike and then
and then induce also a good immune
response against the spike so we are
exploring both modalities of
administration to see which one produce
better protection
so um the study that that i'm showing
here is one of the first studies that we
demise with these newcastle diseases
virus vectors in which we compare one
that is contains the um
the transmembranous plasmid tail of the
of one of the new castles virus proteins
the protein versus the one that is not
anchored into is the wild type spike
protein stabilized and it's not
according to into the various into the
virus envelope and this
intramuscular administration life of the
newcastle this virus in mice
uh a prime boost combination and then we
use also two different flavors of the
new castle disease virus one that
contains the mutations that make it more
immunogenic which is this
l295a mutase
and then when we look for induction of
antibodies in this in this mice that
have been immunized
what we see is that they all induce good
level of elisa binding antibodies
especially the last version of the
vector and when we look to
neutralization they all use also good
levels of neutralization but after
priming perhaps the one that contains
this
transmembrane cytoplasmic tail of the f
protein of ndb
which are in red
they induce high level of antibodies so
the ones that are in green
that contains
the wild type trans membranous plasmic
domain
now if we now uh challenge the the
demise and in this case we challenge the
mice with a mouse adapted size
coronavirus is a little bit different
from the challenge that i saw you before
in which we put with an adenovector
another therapy vector the human hd2
receptor they have now been developed
mouse adapters ask of two so we can
challenge with the sask of two mouse
adapted that we got from ralph barrick
and then we look day four for land titus
in the control animals we see high
levels of viral tyres at a4 but in all
demonized animals we see control of our
infection and not viral tyres in the
lung
and if we look for the presence of
antigen in the length of these animals
we see the antigen in here as little
brownish cells in the lungs of these
animals on the right
but we don't see uh antigen virus
infected cells in the one in the ones
that have been vaccinated
with the vaccine vectors present spike
all right so this is um intramuscular we
have also performing pronasal
immunizations um using the using the
same vectors and then what we see is now
in this intranasally immunized mice
we see nice levels of
antibodies in syrah
week 6 and week 10
at the boosting and if we challenge the
animals again we get a very good
reduction at day two and day five
of um
replication in the case of the ones that
have the improve vector with the spike
with the cytoplasmic
tail and the transmembrane domain uh
replace
from the ones of the glycoprotein of ndb
we don't see any virus at a2 or at d5 in
the lungs of these animals
all right so this is with um with live
viruses which are life attenuated uh
that's what also say in inactivated
vaccine for that we inactivated the
virus and then we give it the
intramuscularly in this case we compare
just
five 10 micrograms and 20 micrograms of
viral proteins given intramuscularly
with lower levels in the presence of a
nature band
we use two attributes here one is arto
tap and then there is other bags against
the ml59 equivalent which are two
clinically relevant attributes
uh and for that we use lower levels of
of antigen five micrograms one microgram
of 0.2 micrograms and when we look to
serum antibodies we get good level of
herosine antibodies but but you can
realize that in the presence of an
achivan
then you get
levels that are equivalent to the ones
that are in the absence of achievement
but with lower amount of viruses so one
microgram plus atovan induced the same
levels of antibodies that 20 micrograms
without adjuvant
and again we challenge now this mice
what we see is that especially the
adjuvanted
vaccine with inactivated with other wax
um all the all the animals that we
tested that they formed with all the
doses 0.2 one micron or five microgram
they they don't have
um viral replication in the lungs we
cannot detect viruses titus in the lungs
of this animal vaccinated
so this looks very good and when we were
doing these studies then the group of uh
jason mclean
found
some way to further stabilize the spike
by introducing not two problems but four
more prolines in six problems is what we
we call it
um in the in the
carboxy terminal domain of the spike
that make it even more tight and more
stable these spikes
so when we saw that then we we compare
the ones with two prolines with the ones
with six prolines
um and that's what we did in the in the
next experiment so using the exa pro we
call it um
and when we compare it we see that if we
use the exa pro is even getting higher
levels antibodies than the previous
version
when the animals are immunized
intramuscularly
and
we look in these animals and now this
experiment with hamsters hamsters are
susceptible to sask of two infection so
uh in this case an intramuscularly
administered inactivated vaccine in the
presence of alavax asachiwan or cpg or
dotap
and then
after we get good levels of antibodies
and when we challenge with suscoff2
especially the
uh
vaccine that has as adjuvant
alabax and
dota the animals still lose almost any
weight as compared to the other animals
so it looks like this is
a good vaccine for both mice and
hamsters
now this intramuscular vaccination uh in
hamsters does reduce our titles and
again the the barrel type especially to
the acuvented
vaccines are they two uh in the lungs of
these animals or at day five we cannot
detect any viral titus as compared to
control animals
and then if we do international
administration in hamsters
we also get very good responses
we get very high levels of antibodies in
sierra
and the animals don't lose any weight
when they have been challenged with
subscribers
so it works both intramuscularly and
intranasal
and
the important thing is that if we look
internationally in not only in lungs but
also in nasal turbinates nasal bosses
and w
then we get a perfect reduction of
altitudes in the lungs at each one of
day five in vaccinated animals
but also in the respiratory tract
upper respiratory tract so we get a
good reduction of altitudes
and some animals nobody titus that are
detectable on day two and certainly not
at day five
okay so how about different variants so
now we have been testing these immunized
animals also
mice or hamsters are immunized with this
vector which is based on the previous
the first equilibrium variance of of
saskatchewan what we call the wohan uh
strains of wuhan-like strength we test
for the ability to neutralize some of
the variants like the b117 or the
altavarian and the be 1.351 and what we
see is that you get still very good
levels of induction of antibodies
neutralizing antibodies doesn't drop
with respect to
the
alpha variant b117
with respect to the to the beta be 1.351
there is a there is some drop this is
happened also with the other vaccines
that are in the market but this drop is
not enough to remove neutralizing
capability
so these immunized animals
are still protected against um
variants and then when we challenge
these animals
with either
um the beta variant which is the one
that solves more of a drop in
neutralization antibodies or also with
the alpha body the the gamma barium t1
then we see also a nice reduction of
titus in the in the uh
mice of the in the lungs of these
animals
all right so that's thus um
all the clinical data that we have and
this has spur
uh with a
funding uh mainly from different
governments
of clinical trials in different parts of
the world using this vaccine approach
uh one of them is vietnam the phase one
trials started in march 15
they are comparing different doses of
inactivated vaccine in volunteers for
safety and immunogenicity
with and without adjuvant this is an
activated
approach
same thing it's been a very similar
studies being conducted in thailand with
slightly different doses and
but also with an activated vaccine
studies at the start of march 22
we are starting to get the data from
these clinical trials the the good thing
is that we have not been able to see any
severe adverse event so it seems to be
working
quite well in terms of safety
and we are now monitoring the
immunogenicity that they are inducing in
vaccinated people in these phase one
trials
and in addition there is another um
another
phase another trial that has been um
started in mexico in which case we use
they are a life
attenuated approach so we
part of the volunteers they receive the
vaccine internationally and
again we are starting to get data from
these ones with the severe adverse
events they don't seem to occur at least
in this group of volunteers
and the immunogenicity we are just
spending for getting this data
so
what i've said is that antigens that are
based on stabilizers protein by removal
of the feeding clivicidal insertion of
prolines are protein immunogens and
these are the preferred antigens to be
used for in vaccine platforms
against sarskoff ii
that a newcastle disease virus makes
vector that express the sarskoff ii that
is stabilize it is by removing the
activity site and putting six prolines
induced potent protection from various
infection both in lungs and nose of
hamsters after intranasal immunization
and the new variants are still
neutralized by syrah from immunized mice
but with some drop of titus of
for the three 1.351 barium but it's
still protection
and two phase one trials have started in
vietnam thailand in mexico uh they have
been started one with a live approach
and we expect soon also trials to start
in brazil and in the usa but we are
still in phase one so it may take still
some time before we we get results of
efficacy for these vaccines but again if
this
tends to be a good vaccine against
um sarskoff ii that would be vaccine
that is more easy to produce
less expensive that the vaccines that
are right now are more affordable
especially for developing countries
which is where the vaccine is still
needed
okay so thanks a lot and
if there is any questions i will be
happy to to answer
thank you so much dr garcia sastre we
appreciate your presentation today
we now will move to the live q a portion
of our webinar and if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's get started
it looks like we have a question already
coming in from our audience
can you reuse an ndv vaccine vector
multiple times in the same individual
and still induce good immune responses
yeah okay so so this uh may
have to do with the need for potentially
future boosters as well as uh
potentially using also newcastle these
virus vectors for vaccination not only
against ascof2 but against other
emerging pathogens or even some passages
like rsv
most usually the problem with using
viral vectors repeated time seconds
against multiple
pathogens later on
or
through boosters
is that these vaccine vectors also
induce immunity against themselves
and then there is a moment that they are
not anymore able to use good immune
responses
now this this could be a problem for
newcastle disease as a
use of a general vaccine platform
against multiple agents
but
the good news is that within the
newcastle this is virus family
there are a lot of antigenically
different
viruses that are also all infecting
avians and they are safe in humans
so one can change the surface
glycoproteins of newcastle disease virus
with the surface glycoproteins or
related viruses which are called avian
paramyxoviruses
that will
make the vowel vector again being able
to work efficiently
in people that have already antibodies
against the previous newcastle this
virus vector that was vaccinated with so
we hope that with that we can bypass
um the potential vector immunity that is
created when we first use one viral
vector and because there are more than
20 antigenically different avion
parameter viruses there is at least 20
different possibilities to make
reuse in different vaccination
approaches in the same individual the
newcastle disease virus
thank you so much for
this opportunity to do a q a with you
and i want to encourage our members that
are attending to submit any additional
questions that any of them that are not
answered today will be answered via
email would you like to provide any
closing remarks for our audience before
we go
well i think it's important uh you know
at this moment
uh to uh
increase the levels of vaccination i
mean there is a lot of
fear perhaps that vaccination is not
working well against the the new
variants
um and that there is waning of immunity
that may actually make people that are
vaccinated vulnerable again
there is a lot of delta variant
circulating now in the in the in the
world
but
but perhaps the vaccines are reduced
efficacy although not completely there
are signals we have right now reduce
efficacy although not completely lose it
against asymptomatic and mild infections
second infections of the upper
respiratory tract which makes a problem
because there's still there is some
virus transmission and especially
non-vaccine individuals that can cause
severe disease but they're still
extremely efficient with respect to
elimination of severe disease
meaning that if we get enough coverage
of vaccination
we will
reduce dramatically the cases of severe
disease
the virus will be still circulating
because the vaccine is not
100 percent vacations especially as i
mentioned against the new variants
but
they
they will eliminate most of the cases of
severe disease making now um this virus
less harm
producing less harm than what it can
produce so so basically right now the
the majority of the cases of severe
disease are happening only
in non-vaccinated individuals so it's
like the pandemic now has
swifted from being a pandemic of
everybody to being pandemic in
non-immunized individuals and
we need to do everything that is
possible to protect the people that are
not immunized
increase the vaccination coverages in
the places that they can afford vaccines
and find new vaccines that may allow to
increase vaccine coverages in the
countries that they don't have the
capability to uh
to
get vaccinated with the existing
vaccines which is what
we try to do with this newcastle this is
virus vector vaccine
well thank you very much dr garcia
sastre for your time again today and for
your important research and before we go
i want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions again we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the
registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for two years until september 9th
2023 laborats will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
from your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
bye-bye everyone
okay goodbye